bonjour à vous philippe chalmin alors le
bureau national de recherche économique
la science c'est bien une récession mais
à votre avis combien de temps cela va
durer
écoutez que ce soit une récession ce
n'est franchement pas un scoop je
rappelle simplement que on convient de
parler de récession
lorsque l'on à deux trimestres de suite
en négatif il est évident que le premier
et le deuxième trimestre de 2020 seront
en négatif on n'a pas encore n'a pas
terminé le deuxième trimestre mais il
est évident que il ya récession aux
états unis
comme il y a récession pratiquement dans
tous les pays du monde
certains d'ailleurs sont officiellement
en récession comme l'allemagne et le
japon qui a été déjà en phase de
ralentissement est donc déjà en
croissance négative au dernier trimestre
de 2010 9
maintenant pour répondre à votre
question combien de temps ça va durer
certainement au moins sur le troisième
trimestre toute la question est de
savoir c'est une main peu de questions
d'alphabet est ce que la reprise
s'apparentera avait alors là ce serait
une reprise rapide a pu on reste un
certain temps en bas et la reprise est
plus lente puis à quelques pessimistes
qu'ils imaginent même 1l remettant la
reprise à décalant de beaucoup plus loin
tu est intrinsèquement de toute manière
pratiquement toutes les économies
mondiales auront une croissance négative
sur l'ensemble de l'année 2020 et il
faut rappeler que ce sera le recul
économique le plus fort que le monde ait
connue depuis 1945 alors vous allez
certainement nous éclairer sur
l'attitude de donald trump qui semble
garder confiance
c'est vrai que le pays connaît un taux
de chômage record mais
la situation elle s'est légèrement
améliorée et donald trump lui et s'en
est vanté comment vous vous l'expliquer
mais après la pluie le beau temps
le problème est de savoir si nous sommes
actuellement en phase des dernières
gouttes ou s'il ya encore quelques
orages à venir
c'est vrai que lorsque l'on regarde le
profil des crises provoquées par la
crise sanitaire
on a une sorte de courbe en cloche donc
un peu identique d'ailleurs à celle tuco
vide et donc la chine
on est à peu près sorti l'europe
commence commence à montrer quelques
signes un peu moins négatifs et il
commence aussi en être un peu
d'eux-mêmes aux états unis sachant que
les états unis ont mis quand même à
d'énormes moyens puisque le care act
donc le plan de relance voté par le
congrès mais halal à l'initiative de la
maison blanche porte sur 3000 milliards
de dollars donc oui il y as reprise mais
comme vous l'avez dit que d'une
quarantaine de millions d'américains
peut-être plus même se sont inscrits au
chômage et il faut se rappeler qu'une
partie d'entre eux ont perdu leur
couverture santé
certains sont couverts par l'équivalent
d'un sécurité sociale medicaid
pour d'autres ça n'est pas le cas donc
la situation est quand même très
difficile
je dirais simplement qu'en terme de
recul économique qui est encore pire en
europe
alors pierre en europe est ce que pour
autant il faut croire donald trump
lorsqu'il dit que son pénis finalement
va rester en tête des puissances
économiques mondiales
oui oui non mais nous sommes en présence
d'un choc totalement atypique si vous
voulez et il leur a touché tout le monde
les états unis vont repartir bien
évidemment bon c'est pour très peu
dieu sait s'il a des défauts mais sur le
corona virus notamment pas de sa faute
si le coronavirus a éclaté et a éclaté
durant une année électorale alors que sa
réélection semble presque acquise face à
un job hayden qui est quand même un peu
pâlot la barbaque considérablement les
cartes
que va-t-il se passer maintenant
les états unis vont probablement
rebondir
de la même manière que la chine est bon
avant que la chine parviennent à
dépasser les états unis en termes de
première puissance économique mondiale
il y aura encore quelques années à
passer et pour l'instant les états unis
continuent à faire la course en tête
les vraies victimes de cette crise se
sont pas mal de pays émergents qui
commençaient à sortir la tête de l'eau
et qui a se retrouve confronté à des
problèmes modèle brésil inde même et
puis n'oublions pas qu'on a aussi une
crise pétrolière et donc tous les pays
qui dépendent dans leur quotidien des
exportations d'hydrocarbures
merci beaucoup à vous philippe chalmin
je rappelle que vous êtes économiste et
fondateur de la société d'études cyclope